sur 100 m
attaqué sur la cavale de l'année quand
on est en confiance
emma moffatt aux posters sait on a là
gigola contrat n'est pas connu à robin
gemalto de l'alimentation a commencé
presque autant qu'un mec
jeudi tous les corps
sa mort
connais tu es quand la secrétaire au
home un auteur à notre vanille troqué ou
qui a demandé ça fait là
six chiots se prépare à semer la panique
à kyoto et tout cela dans un seul but le
renverser le nouveau gouvernement qui
auto est une ville dangereuse
jamais je ne peux j'y serais allé là bas
il est de mon devoir de l'arrêter merci
pour ce que tu m'as apporté au revoir
simon aura refuse de nous aider notre
pays court à sa perte
ici jamais qu'il retrouvait logo depuis
le japon est sur le point de sombrer
dans le chaos danse d'abord à ta vie
avant de sauver celle des autres
quand l'ours l'insurrection attention
attention
tu n'as rien de mieux
reste ici je reviendrai je te le promets
nous reviendrons au temps des jours les
plus sombres de l'insurrection